MALE SPEAKER: Hi, there.
Thank you all for
coming out today.
I'm here to present
Miss Kim Nalley, who's
going to be speaking
about Billie Holiday.
U.C. Berkeley History Ph.D.
Candidate, and jazz and blues
singer, Kim Nalley, will
sketch the life and music
of Eleanora Fagan.
Awarded Most Influential African
American in the Bay Area,
and short-listed for a
Grammy, Nalley portrayed
Holiday on stage in
the theatrical biopic
"Lady Day in Love"
in 2005, followed
with a tribute CD entitled
"Ballads for Billie,"
a sold-out concert
series at Jazz
at Lincoln Center in New York,
and will reprise her tribute
on July 17, 2015, for SFJAZZ.
As a popular writer,
Nalley has written
for sfgate.com's city bright
series, and for JazzWest.
As a scholar, she has written
several jazz-themed history
papers, including "This
Bitter Earth-- Infertility
in Billie Holiday, Ella
Fitzgerald, and Sarah Vaughan;"
and "Two Gardenias for Civil
Rights-- Robin Carson's
Portrait of Billie Holiday."
Her research of Holiday
includes interviews
of people who knew
Billie personally,
painting an intimate, singing
portrait of the woman whose
name is synonymous
with jazz singer.
So, thank you again,
and here's Kim.
[APPLAUSE]
KIM NALLEY: Thank you
so much for having me.
It is the centennial
of the birth
of the woman whose name is
eponymous with the words "jazz
singer," Billie Holiday.
Her legacy is so ingrained,
that although she
was neither the
first nor the last
to wear a flower in
her hair, a songstress
with a flower in her hair
will invariably evoke Billie.
There is a great triumvirate
of vocal jazz, which
consists of Billie Holiday, Ella
Fitzgerald, and Sarah Vaughan.
They were the most creatively
fertile women in their field.
And the fruits of
their creative genius
have set the vocal standards
so high that no other jazz
singer since has come even
close to dethroning the memory
of their musicianship.
Of the three singers,
Billie is the eldest,
and her career
started several years
before Ella, the second-eldest.
Unlike the other singers,
the sensationalism
around Billie Holiday's
personal life was legion.
Before gossip blogs existed,
even before the term
"paparazzi" was coined,
the public's interest
in the lurid details of
Billie Holiday's life
dominated, and it has in many
ways diminished her legacy.
She did not go to
school for music.
She did not read or write music.
But she is clearly a genius.
And yet her genius
is rarely emphasized.
In comparison, there are
few biographical sketches
that avoid delving into her
penchant for abusive men,
and self-destructive drug use.
I recently read a very
terrible centennial piece
on Holiday that attributed
her musical interpretation
of "Lover Man (Oh, where can you
be)" to a longing for heroin.
I do not see the
same attention given
to Miles Davis' or
Charlie Parker's drug use,
or their abusive relationships.
Their women are not given a
megaphone to comment on them,
and I have never seen their
musical genius attributed
to drug use.
I sometimes see the hardships of
being a black man highlighted,
but I do not see the same
courtesy given to Miss Holiday.
So I would like to put her
life in historical context.
Billie Holiday was born
Eleanora Fagan on April 7, 1915,
in Philadelphia, but she
was raised in Baltimore.
Now Baltimore was not a
residentially segregated town
in 1860, on the eve
of the Civil War.
Less than 4% of blacks
lived in cities.
But by the 1900s, thousands
of African Americans
migrated into cities
looking for work,
and safety from white
Redemption, which massacred
and terrorized blacks throughout
the South after Reconstruction
ended.
With the influx of
African Americans,
Baltimore soon became
residentially segregated,
and the construction of
the B&O railroad displaced
several African Americans
into already filled slums.
Overcrowding and the lack
of sanitation in these slums
caused an outbreak of
typhoid and tuberculosis
of epic proportions.
One black neighborhood was
grimly nicknamed lung block.
Urbanization, industrialization,
and depression in Baltimore
had concentrated in a growing
population of the poor,
the sick, and the ignorant.
By the nineteen-teens, the
decade of Billie Holiday's
birth, several
residential ordinances,
passed by progressives and
bolstered by Social Darwinist
ideology, made
residential segregation
both de facto and de jure.
Baltimore became such a
highly segregated city
that in legal studies,
it remains the prime city
to study to understand
the birth of segregation.
This was the world that Billie
Holiday was born into in 1915.
Her neighborhood was
called "Pigtown."
Here is how it was described.
"Open drains; great lots
filled with high weeds;
ashes, and garbage
accumulated in the alleyways.
Cellars filled with
filthy black water.
Houses that are total strangers
to the touch of white wash
or scrubbing brush.
Human bodies that
have been strangers
for months to soap and water.
Villainous-looking Negroes,
who loiter and sleep
around the street
corners, and never work.
Vile and vicious
women with but a smock
to cover their black nakedness,
lounging in the doorways,
or squatting upon the
steps, hurling foul epithets
at every passerby.
Foul streets, foul
people, and foul tenements
filled with foul air.
That is Pigtown."
Billie Holiday was the offspring
of a one-night dalliance
at a carnival between
16-year-old Clarence Holiday
and 18-year-old Sarah
Harris, nee Fagan,
who was nicknamed Sadie.
The two never
married, and did not
appear to have much
of a relationship
beyond the night that
created baby Eleanora.
There is little
evidence that Clarence
had contact with Sadie,
and even less evidence
of financial support.
Jobs for black
women were limited,
and Sadie had difficulty
finding work as a live-in maid,
because white families
usually did not
allow black children
to accompany
their live-in, domestic maids.
As a consequence,
Billie intermittently
did not live with her mother,
and was instead shunted
around various
maternal relatives.
The clothing inside
of this picture
were likely secondhand
discards from Sadie's employer.
On the occasion that she
did live with her mother,
they, like many poor or
African Americans at that time,
lived in boarding houses.
In 1925 Billie was
living with her mother
in a Baltimore
boarding house, when
a much older man, who was also
a boarder at the residence,
raped her.
It was Christmas Eve.
Billie was 11 years old.
The man was arrested.
Billie was placed in
protective custody
at a reform school called the
House of the Good Shepherd
for Colored Girls.
This reform school is often
described as a prison,
and "fallen women" were
frequently placed there.
There are several accounts of
abuse and girls running away.
Her mother had to
hire a lawyer in order
to get Billie released.
And so Billie
Holiday's first brushes
with the law as a
prepubescent child
results in her being
locked up, even though she
was the one that was raped.
After reform school, Billie
began to run errands at a place
called Alice Dean's.
It was not a formal
whorehouse, but was rather
described as a "clip 'em
and let 'em go joint,"
where one could smoke reefer,
listen to the Victrola,
and if they wanted to,
they could turn a trick.
Most people could not afford
a Victrola and the records
to play on it, so to be
at a place that played
records was quite an event.
At Alice Dean's, Billie
Holiday heard Bessie Smith,
the Empress of the blues.
Billie claimed Bessie Smith,
along with Louis Armstrong,
as one of her
seminal influences.
Billie would later record one
of Bessie Smith's famous songs,
"'Taint Nobody's Business If I
Do," to her own great acclaim.
When Billie Holiday
turned 13, Sadie
began working at a proper
whorehouse called Florence's
inside of New York City.
She sent for her daughter
to come and stay with her.
When Billie Holiday
arrived, she discovered
she was expected to work
there as a prostitute.
There are no photos of
Billie and her mother
from this time period.
So this photo that you see here
is from a later time period.
I only can impress
upon you in words
that Billie Holiday,
a very young teenager,
was transported
across state lines
to work as a child sex
slave by her mother.
We often forget
how young 12 and 13
years old is when we speak
of African Americans.
And even today the law
increasingly treats
black and brown
children as adults.
I encourage people to watch
the film "Pretty Baby,"
with 12-year-old
Brooke Shields, so
that they can get the full
visceral impact of youth forced
into prostitution, and try
to afford the same emotions
for Billie Holiday.
Within months of working
at Florence's, Billie
was arrested.
And although she was one month
shy of her 14th birthday,
she gave the police
a false age of 21,
probably to avoid
another juvenile home.
And consequentially,
she was convicted
as an adult. After
doing four months time
on Welfare Island, which is
now known as Roosevelt Island,
she was released in 1929,
the beginning of the Great
Depression.
Billie decided to
stop turning tricks,
and to place her bets on
getting a job as an entertainer.
She said, "I always
knew I could sing.
I just didn't know I
could make money at it."
So instead of singing,
she auditioned as a dancer
at Pod's and Jerry's Club.
But she danced poorly.
And at the suggestion
of the audition pianist,
she sang a song, and
was immediately hired.
She changed her
last name to Holiday
in order to capitalize on
her father, who by that time
was a guitarist in one
of the most-respected
black big bands, the
Fletcher Henderson Orchestra.
The first name Billie
is from Billie Dove,
a famous actress from
that time period known
as The American Beauty.
This next picture is a photo of
Billie Holiday at approximately
16 or 17 years of age.
This is the only
known photograph
of her as a teenager in
which she is not working.
Billie's fortitude is amazing.
She never really
had a childhood,
yet she turned her rotten
lemons into lemonade.
She grabbed control of
her life at the tender age
of 14 years old,
so that she could
become a professional singer.
However it's very
important to not
have any illusions
about what the jazz
life was like back then.
There was a prohibition on
alcohol in the United States
in 1929, and it does
not end until 1933.
Her gigs were speakeasies
run by gangsters,
who specialized in
this transport and sale
of illegal, bootleg substances.
These speakeasies were no
Jazz at Lincoln Center,
or San Francisco Jazz
Center, or any other type
of reputable music place.
She grew up in a rough world
full of hustlers and gangsters.
It is small wonder she
attached herself to tough men.
These were the type of
men who could protect her
in these types of environments.
There was no other option.
Women and bands
were property that
could be passed from
one owner to another.
There was no choice involved.
It was simple necessity.
One of Billie Holiday's
first regular gigs
was singing in Queens
for $18 a week.
And so you can get an idea of
how much money that was back
then, you should know that
maids got $0.50 a day.
This photo over
here, is not known
what year it is, but I think
that it's probably also 1935,
because she appears to
be wearing the same dress
that she's wearing
outside of the Apollo
with Ben Webster;
Ram Ramirez, who
is the person who wrote
"Lover Man (Where Can You Be);
Johnny Russell.
You can see her
later in 1939, she
seems to be wearing a
little better dresses,
but they're still not
quite fitting very well.
She kept getting
fired from her gigs,
because she wouldn't
sing the tunes straight.
But nonetheless, her
originality caught the attention
of record producer
John Hammond, who
arranged her first recording
with Benny Goodman Orchestra
1933.
Now it would seem
that by the time
Billie Holiday made her
Apollo debut in 1934
that she was already
established, having recorded
with Benny Goodman.
But she wanted to be working
in Manhattan, not Queens.
Clarence "Pop" Foster,
the MC of the Apollo,
said she was a fat slob who
wore the same common, ugly dress
every night.
Excuse me-- he was the
comedian, not the MC.
However, ugly polka
dot dress or not, she
competed, and won first prize
with the song "The Man I Love."
After that, she was able to get
more gigs inside of Manhattan.
She started working at a Mexican
place called the Hot-Cha,
and formed a close
bond with her father.
This is a picture of
Billie Holiday's New York.
And it's a great photo,
because it illustrates
how dense the scene is.
This fertile jazz scene is
a product of segregation,
and a concentration of talent
in a very small radius.
They could sit in with
each other on set breaks,
catch another person's show
before or after their show.
You can see that over
here under the 3 Deuces,
that Oscar Pettiford is playing.
And then right down the street,
you can see a little bit of it,
there's Art Tatum who's playing.
Pod's and Jerry's, where
she gets her first audition,
is right there.
And then there's the Onyx,
which is a club that she later
plays at, inside of her career.
It is then that she runs into
the amazing pianist Teddy
Wilson, and embarks upon
a series of recordings
for the Brunswick label.
Teddy Wilson was just
a master of rearranging
bargain-bin tunes.
He and Billie would take
tunes, and they would
be completely unrecognizable.
And they would have
hits with them,
where nobody else would
touch these tunes.
It was more like
rewriting the songs
than actually covering them.
This next picture
is of Lester Young.
Billie Holiday was already
established inside of New York
by the time Lester Young
got into Manhattan.
And she took him under her wing.
And she let him live
with her and her mom,
and got him recording dates.
And they had a very, very
close musical romance.
They were not physically
involved with each other,
but they had a very deep,
deep, deep special love
with each other.
He is the person that
gave her the name "Lady,"
and she, "Pres," for
president, because he
was the top cat in the country.
Shortly after,
Billie Holiday began
playing with the Count
Basie Band, which
is one of my favorite bands.
It was just a very
popular jump blues band.
During the same period, Ella
was singing with the Chick Webb
orchestra.
And so, in 1937, when
the very famous battle
of the bands at
the Savoy Ballroom
happened, between Chick
Webb and Count Basie,
it was also another contest
between Ella Fitzgerald
and Billie Holiday.
There's almost no
recordings of this period,
because Billie Holiday and Count
Basie were signed to competing
record label contracts.
However the newspapers
who covered the event very
thoroughly said that,
"Chick Webb kicked
Count Basie's band's butt, but
Billie won over Ella Fitzgerald
hands down."
It seems like this would have
been a match made in heaven,
Billie Holiday and Count Basie.
But unfortunately,
Billie Holiday
quit Count Basie's
band-- or was fired
for not wanting to
sing blues tunes--
and she joined
Artie Shaw's band.
If you take a jazz
history class now,
Artie Shaw is not one of the
people you'll probably study.
But I assure you that he
was very, very famous,
and he was much more famous
than Count Basie at that time
period.
This was her chance
to make it big,
and to be a cross-over success.
Touring with Artie Shaw on
a national level exposed
Billie to virulent racism
and Jim Crow conditions
inside of the South,
forcing her to defecate
on the side of the road,
and wait in the kitchen
in between tunes; and
subjected to audiences
yelling, "Let the nigger
wench sing another tune."
The final straw came when
segregation on the radio waves
forced the band to
replace Billie Holiday's
voice with Helen Forrest
for an important broadcast.
Billie quit and went back to
New York to meet her destiny.
She started working at
a place in the Village
called the Cafe Society.
The Cafe Society was a
hip Greenwich Village
bar filled with intellectuals,
bohemians, and artists.
It was there in 1939 that
she was introduced to
and began performing
the song "Strange
Fruit," an anti-lynching protest
song written by Jewish writer
Abel Meeropol.
This song catapulted
Billie Holiday
into a new kind of stardom.
The owner of Cafe
Society was hip enough
to not only let
her sing the song,
but to demand absolute silence.
No cash register
buttons were pushed.
No drink orders were taken.
There was no whispering.
And he gave her a black
room, with a tight spotlight
on her face.
She recorded "Strange Fruit"
on Billy Crystal's uncle's
brand-new Commodore label,
because her label, Columbia,
wouldn't touch the song.
This song, and her performances
of it at the Cafe Society,
turned Billie Holiday
into a legend.
She was no longer the singer
of sentimental love songs.
She became a race woman,
an outspoken proponent
of civil rights,
more than 15 years
before "Brown versus Board of
Education," and almost 20 years
before the March on Washington.
What is less considered
about "Strange Fruit"
is the song's
communist background.
Abel Meeropol was a communist
who, like most communists,
believed in racial equality.
He is also famous for adopting
the Rosenberg children,
whose parents, Julius
and Ethel Rosenberg,
were executed for passing
nuclear information
to the Soviets, even though
the United States and the USSR
were World War II
allies at that time.
"Strange Fruit" began as a poem,
printed in a teacher's union
paper under the
pseudonym of Lewis Allan.
The song was
printed again inside
of The New Masses,
a Marxist magazine.
How much persecution did
Meeropol, a white Jewish man,
face that compelled him to
publish it under a pseudonym?
As opposed to Holiday,
a black woman,
who sang it publicly in person,
and attached her livelihood
to it.
It is important not
to overlook the fact
that communism was active
in promoting civil rights
and racial equality.
The connection between
communism and racial equality
was so strong that
during the McCarthy era,
people working for
racial equality
were summarily labeled
communists, or at the very
least, pinkos.
There are several accounts
of artistic careers ruined
during the McCarthy
era of the '50s.
These are the same years that
coincided with the last decade
of Billie Holiday's life.
All in all, Billie Holiday's
life spanned 30 years.
She recorded from her teens
until her death in 1959
at the age of 44.
There are very, very few
artists, especially vocalists,
who can claim a recording
career with such length.
Shirley Horn, Etta Jones,
Jimmy Scott, Alberta Hunter,
and many others, all
fell out of the spotlight
for decades before
making comebacks.
While much to-do is made over
the changes in Billie Holiday's
voice over the decades,
any classical vocal student
can tell you that a
voice, like an athlete,
peaks at a certain age, and
declines despite one's best
efforts to preserve it.
Billie Holiday's change
is often accompanied
by accusations of
self-destruction,
but I myself admire the
genius of her later years.
It is a study in minimalism
and breath control.
Her lyricism is resplendent,
and improvisation is so great
that the melody at
times is unrecognizable
from the published sheet music.
Yet so direct and simple,
that her improvisation
is more melodic than
the original melody.
Her final studio
album, "Lady in Satin,"
was borrowed from my
collection and was never
returned so often that I
purchased it eight times
before the digital
world rendered
such extended loans impossible.
It's never Billie Holiday's
early material that's
stolen from my collection.
It's always the older material.
Her musical offerings are on par
with John Coltrane, and Parker,
and should be
considered as such.
So the next time you read an
article on Billie Holiday's
life, remember that
she was a genius who
battled virulent segregation,
racism, sexism, rape,
molestation, and sexual abuse.
She was trafficked into
child sexual slavery,
and possibly even sterilized
in prison against her will,
due to the eugenic
politics of her time.
And somehow, Holiday took
the crap she was given,
and grew violets for her furs.
She truly is one of the
most important artists
of the 20th century.
And now, if you
have any questions,
I'd be happy to take them.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So, I was going
to ask, when did you
first discover Billie Holiday?
And how did your interest grow?
KIM NALLEY: She was
one of the artists
that I listened to growing up
inside of my childhood home.
And along with Nina
Simone, and Nancy Wilson,
we were fed a steady diet of
them, and Ella Fitzgerald.
So I can't remember a time
where I didn't know them.
And then my great-uncle
was also a jazz drummer,
who played with Dexter Gordon.
So I kind of come from
a family of musicians
for a few generations.
AUDIENCE: What did you
think of Diana Ross?
KIM NALLEY: What did I
think about Diana Ross?
At the time, I really
disliked it as a child.
They just took so many
liberties with her story.
So what happened with
Billie Holiday is,
she married Louis McKay right
before she died, because they
were arrested for drugs.
And so they married,
so that way they
wouldn't have to testify against
each other inside of court
under coverture.
So it just so happened
that when she died,
Louis McKay inherited
her entire property.
And he was a hustler
and pimp, and he
decided to spin it so
that he was the savior.
And he got Billy Dee
Williams to play himself.
But he was absolutely
terrible, and terrible to her.
So I wasn't impressed with
it at all, even as a kid.
AUDIENCE: Where do
you suggest that we
find reliable information
if we want to learn more?
KIM NALLEY: I was just thinking
right before I came here,
I should have had the last
slide be a bibliography.
So there are a few different
books, biographies,
that are really great.
One is by Donald Clarke.
The other is by
Stuart Nicholson.
And those are very basic
books that probably everybody
or anybody has.
There's also the auto--
her "autobiography,"
"Lady Sings the Blues,"
which is riddled with a lot
of inaccuracies.
But at least it gives
you a step to go into it
and learn some more.
I would say one of
my favorite books
on Billie Holiday is
called "On Billie,"
and it's just a collection
of oral histories,
the first person interviews
with people that knew her,
including people that
played with her when
she was 10, 11, 13.
And the quote from Pops Foster,
that she was a big, fat slob
with big titties.
That's what he really
thought of her back then.
And I think those
are really great.
Her secretary is
included in that.
And then beyond that,
there is Robert O'Meally,
who is a wonderful scholar.
He is a English literature.
And he wrote a beautiful
book on Billie Holiday.
And it's a really nice
coffee table book.
And it has a lot of
beautiful photographs
that I've never seen before.
And he is an academic
scholar, so it's meticulously
researched.
So it's more than just
a coffee table book.
But it's really nice.
AUDIENCE: One is, how
did she make transition
from the world of prostitution
to the world of entertainment,
or did she keep some
of the connections
with the underworld
of prostitution?
And the second question is,
what was her relationship
to the Civil Rights Movement
in the '50s, before she passed?
KIM NALLEY: Well, she
made a very clean break
from prostitution into
singing at the age of 14.
And the pay scale
for singing was such
that it was enough to keep
you out of prostitution.
She was getting paid
more as a jazz singer
than she would get
as a prostitute.
So that's pretty clear.
But again, as I mentioned-- you
might have missed the earlier
part-- the world
of jazz singing,
there was a great
amount of overlap.
So the people frequenting the
clubs during that time period
were frequently hustlers,
and pimps, and prostitutes.
And definitely lots
of white people
who wanted to slum it, and avid
fans, and a good mix of crowd.
Just performing at the Cafe
Society was a civil rights act.
It was an integrated club,
and it was more than just
integrated meaning
that the races mixed,
but they were actually
treated equally.
And that was almost not the
case in most of the places
in Harlem inside of this period.
Most of these places
had black entertainment
for white patrons.
But it's hard to talk about
her inside of the same breath,
because what we think of as
the modern-day Civil Rights
Movement is really a
'60s kind of thing.
And she dies in '59.
So she really predates it.
And she is just a really early
forerunner inside of the Civil
Rights Movement, definitely.
AUDIENCE: I know you
mentioned "Lady in Satin."
I'd love to hear, if you're
thinking about listening more
into her music collection,
what else would you recommend?
What are your favorites?
What really shows the range?
KIM NALLEY: There is
a box set by Columbia,
and Columbia is the
record label that she
was on during her
early years, that
really shows the range of her
voice when she was younger.
And it also has her very
first two recordings
with Benny Goodman that
nobody possibly would know,
unless you happen to
have this box set.
And her voice is very bell-like,
and it's very, very, very
clear, and very high,
and very girlish.
And then I think that most of
us are very familiar with Billie
Holiday in the later
years, where it's a drawl,
and you can hear all the
vocal fry in her voice.
That's so recognizable.
But that Columbia box
is really, really nice.
And again, that
has a booklet in it
that has a lot of
beautiful pictures
that you could put
on your coffee table.
It's probably about
11 by 17 liner notes.
It's really nice.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, Kim,
for speaking to us today.
KIM NALLEY: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]